no one who complains about
overpopulation has ever been the good
guy
ever in history if you are complaining
about overpopulation you are on the bad
team none of the people who complain
about overpopulation are ever
volunteering themselves to take a ticket
off the ship it's always that someone
else shouldn't have life it's always
that someone else should hurry along and
die I feel happy
it's never that they themselves want to
do they want to go to parties and Davos
and they want to have nice drinks and
they want to have a bunch of hookers
apparently according to the reports
coming out of Davos there is just an
army of prostitutes descending on the
town well they have their fun and they
eat their fancy foods and they drink
their fancy drinks and they do various
activities with their fancy ladies of
the night they talk about how you should
not even have the right to live